welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and we just got some new footage
for miss marvel coming to disney plus
the new marvel series following the
character of kamala khan a captain
marvel adjacent muslim pakistani
american teenager living in new jersey a
potential member of the young avengers
but definitely confirmed to join captain
marvel and monica rambo in the marvels
there is so much that i love about this
character that i've been waiting to see
in the mcu i can't wait to react to this
footage so i'm going to give you my
reaction my first thoughts and then i'm
going to go through and point out some
interesting stuff that you might have
missed from this footage as limited as
it is so without further ado let's react
to this here we go
let's talk about you
it's not really the brown girls from
jersey
you city the world
maybe now they do
yeah now that's right totally
the costume is insane
[Music]
ah yes okay so in this series iman
valani is playing kamala khan who goes
by the name of miss marvel she actually
got her first appearance in the comics
as part of a captain marvel series in
2013 but she was such a popular
character that a lot of people wanted to
see again so she got her own run in 2014
she's a muslim pakistani american
teenager living in new jersey in the
comics she gets her powers by being
covered in terrigen mist that's what
turns people into inhumans and she gets
wrapped up in a cocoon and sees this
cool vision of the other avengers
talking to her she's known for an
ability to basically embiggen her limbs
and stretch and shape-shift but in the
show it sounds like they're gonna tone
that down because they don't want her to
be too similar to what reed richards mr
fantastic will be instead give her a
green lantern style ability to project
giant shapes off of her body like a
giant genie fist now going through this
footage we see her marveling at this
projection of captain marvel a kind of
display that's projected with all these
different planets probably the planets
she bragged to rhodey that she was
saving and this is the exact look that
she had at the end of the captain marvel
film with the hair and the kind of
mohawk over her head this looks like
it's some kind of exhibit because
there's a sign behind this that says new
jersey avengers if you think about it
the state of new jersey has a lot of
claim to avengers history from the
location of camp lehigh where captain
america trained also the same location
where captain america returned to and
found that freaking zolo was still alive
let's also not forget westview new
jersey ain't too far away from here so
yeah if it weren't for the garden state
we might not have some of our favorite
heroes right and yeah you can also see
new jersey avengers written on their
necklace badges so this is some kind of
celebratory event that they've both
gotten tickets to and you can see she
has a captain marvel patch on her jacket
she's a huge captain marvel stand but
this video is brought to you by the
ridge the ridge wallet is light sleek
and industrial it's designed to fit in
your front pocket unlike those bulky
monstrosities that make us sit crooked
when they're in our back pockets the
ridge comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash so you can show
off your fancy euro collection to
cashiers and other people who probably
don't care every ridge wallet comes with
a lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it they also have great backpacks phone
cases and other cool gear so get 10 off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description i think the
question is going to be how exactly
kamala khan gets her powers in the mcu
we see her at an event kind of
cosplaying as captain marvel with a
bunch of other avengers being
represented here someone's wearing some
iron man cosplay we see a captain
america shield looks like someone maybe
as nebula kind of party where there's a
lot of avengers represented but then she
gets hit by the shock wave of radiation
aesthetically it looks almost exactly
like monica rambo's moment going through
the westview hex wall in wandavision but
from wana vision we know that monica
rambo already had some kind of powers
even before the first time she went into
west view this was kind of like the
third stage of radioactive exposure that
she got and it's also linked to the
aesthetics of when carol danvers got her
power carol danvers case it was
radiation from that light speed engine
that was power derived from the
tesseract from the space stone but it's
some kind of cosmic radiation that is
affecting all three of these women
specifically and i say specifically
because in this shot it looks like only
that radiation is hitting kamala not any
of the other party goers which is
fascinating it tells us that there's
something unique about them to where
this radiation affects them in a unique
way as opposed to anyone who it might
touch could this be marvel's way of
saying there's something genetically
predisposed about specific people in
this universe instead of making kamala
khan an inhuman are they gonna say in
the mcu she is a mutant something that
could also go for monica rambo for carol
danvers for wanda maximoff who had the
ability as a girl to cast low level
hexes before those powers were amplified
from infinity stone radiation so that
could be how mutants come about in the
mcu people who already had an x gene
something that was not activated yet
until shock waves from infinity stone
radiation spread out all over the place
affecting only certain people
specifically who knows maybe in
multiverse of madness when wanda
maximoff goes crazy she could spread
that cosmic radiation universe-wide
activating and awakening an x-gene in
certain people causing mutants to spring
up all over the universe and one of
those mutants could be kamala khan look
i know kamala khan's not a mutant per se
in the comics i'm just saying that's one
way i could see the mcu going with her
character i mean iman vilani seems to be
playing such an endearing character with
her own diy suit where it looks like she
just painted over a jacket like we're
getting a lot of tonal reminders of uh
peter parker and spider-man homecoming
actually peter parker in civil war a
character who never imagined to be able
to play in the big leagues but through
these freak occurrences can now fight
alongside them save their asses and
similar to spider-man homecoming a lot
of that action is gonna be happening at
the high school i love how the door
explodes and right beside it is a sign
saying it's a blast to be a cheerleader
and then we see four other figures
standing in the misty alleyway could
just be other mutants who were triggered
by this radiation shockwave in her world
that kamala khan has to face and then as
she stands on the rooftop with bruno
kind of like a test run of her powers
you see the perspective of everyone down
on the street looking up at her and you
can see in the reflection of the glass
in the building she is totally running
through the air creating these little
cosmic lily pads that she can leap upon
giving her kind of flight powers but
allowing her to run on any surface she
wants i'm just so pumped to see this
younger pressure perspective enter the
mcu i think it's going to be one of the
most endearing characters we've seen in
the mcu yet and i think someone who
might have the most creative handle of
this kind of power set that we've seen
from captain marvel from monica rambo
because as like a marvel cinematic
universe nerd i'm not crazy about seeing
just like energy being balled up or
streamed or blowing through stuff it's
just kind of non-specific and you can
see the clockwork in the actor's eyes as
they're trying to imagine what the cgi
will look like once it's finished as
opposed to something that just feels
like it's a natural extension of their
characters but i feel like kamala khan
is going to be the game changer there as
a kid who's idolized characters with
these powers she's gonna be someone who
truly knows how best to use it how much
creatively to manipulate it someone who
just in her bedroom mirror has been
imagining herself using these kind of
powers so let me know what you thought
about this miss marvel footage i can't
wait to see this show you can support me
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me at eavos follow me rockstars
on social media subscribe to rockstars
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you